there's no question that parents
students and teachers
have all been discussing the events of
tuesday it's all on our minds today was
the last day of class for ccsd students
and mary jane bellies spent some time on
campus
it's the last day of school for clark
county students as parents reflect on
the past year they tell me safety has
always been top of mind today now more
than ever chantal thomas was shocked to
hear about another tragedy in a school
she thinks there needs to be more of a
police presence at our schools i feel
that'll make a difference i mean they're
at the high schools they're not at the
elementaries because they don't feel as
though things will take place at the
elementary like that della smith has a
daughter at owen roundy elementary in
the west side of town she says you can't
help but be involved because i come up
here all through the day
even besides dropping off at school i
still come through the evening time and
check on it milton lovings has two young
kids i've lived here almost 32 years now
so
you know i've seen a lot of people come
and go and
you know it could happen but we wish it
doesn't he says navigating through the
pandemic was hard enough and now the
fear of more school shootings
transitioning from doing computers over
back into school was hard for my kids
but we managed for luis gamboa this
brings back a flood of memories when he
was in school during covey they made
like things really hard for me
i almost failed my senior year now 18
he's worried about his 13 year old
brother who was a student at cram middle
school in north las vegas i just i was
kind of sad about it because
it's kids mary jane vallieza live local
now